Do you ever feel like you do too much?
Like maybe I just need to take a little break here.
Do you ever feel like that?
I think the perception definitely perceives reality.
You know,
uh,
what it looks like so much isn't always so much because you have a schedule and
you know,
within that schedule there's the things that mean the most that come and act as
downtime.
You know,
me and my house is downtime even though it's still active and I got to be dad
and I'm with the kids and a wife in this conversation and I'm running around in
the back and forth.
That's still acts is downtime for me.
Like I'm shutting the work off so the phone is in the office.
I'm not going back to get it until the morning and it's all conversation.
It's all TV,
it's all Taco Tuesdays.
It's couch and cuddling,
uh,
you know,
baby time,
whatever.
That's my downtime because,
um,
I've taken a step outside of the other shit that's was,
that's,
that's what I think I do very well.
I can step outside the other shit.
I can separate it.
So I think when you're able to do that,
then you're,
you're managing your,
your mental,
you know what I mean?
Like if it's,
if it's always one thing all the time,
that's how you fucking drive yourself crazy because you never,
you never shutting it off.
Yeah.
And I think I do a good job of shutting,
shutting this off and focusing on this.
Like when I'm with my family,
I'm with my family.
Nothing is,
nothing interjects or comes in between.
That's fantastic.
That's so important.
It's 100%.
That's beautiful.
100% shout out.
That's gigantic.
I think I figured it out.
That's it,
man.
I think I figured it out.
You mean you've got so much success as long as you have to be with that fucking
phone all the time.
That's the phone is the big one,
right?
The phone.
The phone is,
is the gift and the curse,
you know,
I think that we,
we shut out the gate and saw the Gif.
Oh my God.
It's,
it's,
it's community is connecting us.
We're able to share.
We're able to meet new people where we're able to stay in communication with,
with old people,
find new people.
As an entertainer,
I can engage with my fans and this is so dope.
And then after that you get hit with the curse.
And the curse is,
there's a,
there's a high level of negativity that's out there that's on that shit.
You know,
there's,
there's a lot of people that are,
you know,
not happy or,
or going through things and they interject a,
a certain amount of negativity and hatred through these devices.
These devices are the easiest way to touch everybody.
So when you're just consumed on that shit all day,
you start to see yourself being a part of the negative shit.
Yeah.
So what I've learned to do is go and I don't,
I don't need to see that.
I don't need to see that shit.
I don't,
I don't pay that any mind.
I don't read that shit for,
it's not,
it's not helping me.
It's not making me better.
It's not,
it's not a pushing me to new limits.
If anything is taken up,
just creative space by me.
Literally spending time going in,
in and navigating through what I think is is a bunch of bullshit.
So I don't let the device beat me.
And at one point I definitely did.
At one point it was everything.
It was everything.
It was,
you know,
now separated.
I'm not clear of it.
What you've realized,
what are they?
Is when you see,
when you see the bed,
you know when you see the bad side of it.
I thought the other day this is some real shit and it really made me think my
phone died,
my phone died and I'm driving and I was using the fucking maps and I was like,
Oh shit,
what the fuck?
How am I get to work?
I don't know where I'm going.
And I sat and I was like,
Yo,
how did we,
how did we get from point a to point B before the map?
Shit,
what,
what are we doing that,
I used to print out directions from Google maps.
I remember that.
But then before that,
how did you get to the places where you were going that you didn't know how to
get to?
I don't even remember.
Do you remember Thomas Guides?
Do you ever have a Thomas Card?
I did have a Thomas Guide when I first moved to La.
I get one of them did have a guy giant ask a 100% bill burr had one or two or
three years ago.
I probably still uses it,
shuts off the pool but it really fucked me up because I was like how do we don't
even know how,
how to do the common,
the the norm anymore because the device has made everything available and I
literally had to to drive to a store racket,
buy a charger to charge up my phone to get back and use the map to get to where
the fuck I was going.
I said I had no idea how to get there.
I had no,
I didn't know know numbers by heart.
I didn't know who I was going to call like Yo,
this is the moment where I was like,
what level of success have I reached?
I just pulled over and I sat there and I was like,
how the fuck am I going get the wrong goal?
Spare phone man.
I don't know what it went back up phone.
It felt like the end of the world.
It felt,
it felt like it was over.
I was like shit.
And that crazy how dependent you are.
But that's when the light bulb started to click.
Yeah,
it started to click.
Like how?
How do we function with out?
I want to go backwards a little bit.
Yeah,
it's still there.
I still need it.
I still think is dope with all of the things that we can do on it,
but I still want to be able to put it down and step away from it.
I want my kids to be able to step away from it.
That's why when I come in the house,
my phone was up cause I can't,
I can't bitch and complain at all about being on your phone if you see me doing
the same thing.
Right.
So that time,
those conversations,
me wanting to know about your day,
you talking to me about your day,
your friends who you like,
who don't you like my daughter.
You what boy?
Who,
what?
No,
God,
my son.
Yeah.
I like somebody who,
oh,
Jesus.
Here in comms is,
it's a great thing and I want to be able to have those moments and you know,
I think it's,
it's,
it's big to make sure that you prioritize that.
Are you worried about what comes next?
100%.
I'm worried that something's going to be way more intrusive than that.
It's what he means.
It's already happened.
The biggest scare happened already.
What the,
the,
the facetime shit that happened where,
well,
apple,
uh,
on the iPhones it was like people could listen in to your,
oh yeah.
If you didn't need to pick up.
Yeah.
They could just listen into it and you know,
that was the scariest shit ever.
Because if it's that easy to have a bug like that,
what's the thing that's not a bug that's there that you just don't know about?
Oh,
there's definitely government listened to us.
100% yeah,
100% everything everybody says and then in case one day you do something wrong,
they go back to your side.
Mr. Hart,
we would like you to sit down for a minute.
Why am I you something hundred percent.
So the fear is the next level of the merge intrusive,
you know,
everything is become intrusive now.
Like the toughest thing for me is that there is no,
there is no privacy outside my home.
Right.
You know,
the,
the amount of money that you have to now spend just on security on,
you know,
people to to be with me,
security to be on my home.
You know,
it's like there literally is no privacy and it's not a bitch and complain about
it because without the fans,
without the people that support me,
I wouldn't be where I am.
But there is no middle ground.
Right.
You know,
there is no handshakes anymore.
It's,
it's how you doing.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
The handshake is so much better to get a moment like,
um,
we can talk if that's what you know.
Nah.
Yo saying now it's kind of weird cause you,
you're doing this to me,
it's kind of weird to have a conversation.
So you're just starting to see yourself become a little older and wiser and uh,
just really see the times for what they are and see the direction that we're
going in this people and just hope and pray that we find a middle ground.
Because I think right now there isn't one.
Yeah,
that's what I'm feeling now.
No,
I feel it too.
And especially,
I mean what you're talking about is you being super famous and losing all your
privacy,
but everyone's losing their privacy then slowly but surely it's,
it's happening to you because you're very famous and because you do something
that's in the public eye and people want to see you and they want to stick their
camera in front of you.
But there's gonna come a point in time where what we're dealing with now,
which is like you have to turn your phone on,
you have to,
you know,
you have to reach out to somebody,
you have to put something up that's,
that step's going to be out of the way and it's just going to be people being
able to access your life.
Yeah.
Pretty.
You know,
you know the bed.
Here's what I'll say is bad.
That really fucks with me.
I don't like that negativity is the the want.
Yeah.
Like,
like the,
the thing that's popular is the failure.
The fuck up.
You know,
the,
the fight,
the racking catch the hate for moment that I can catch in posts like the bed is
being highlighted and celebrated.
That's what fucks with me.
What the social media shit.
Now what,
what really bothers me is,
you know,
when you see these things online,
like you know,
a fight and there was a man hitting a woman and is captured.
Right.
That's bad.
The bad thing is that you watched that the video was more important than the
actual help or the moment to step in and you know when you see these things
where you're catching people do these things,
the kids and this caught the moment of what you got in what you want to post and
get likes or whatever on is the focus instead of the help and that and that's,
that's the part that is just,
I just have a hard time processing.
I have a hard time processing what the likes mean to certain people,
but you get an extraordinary amount of attention so it doesn't mean anything to
you.
It means something to a regular person,
a regular person.
They can catch some worldstar video and put it up there like,
dude,
that's my video.
That's my video.
My video got 5 million hits,
my video has gone viral,
my videos everywhere.
For them it's like it's a point of excitement.
That's why when they see you they're like,
oh shit.
How often are they going to run into Kevin Hart at Costco or wherever the fuck
you were.
Definitely running right up to me on,
uh,
you know,
I'm in a,
I'm in the bathroom,
um,
restaurant and I go to the bathroom,
you know,
by the way that I went to the bathroom,
you could definitely tell I had to shit.
I was,
I was moving fast.
you know,
it was one of those abrupt,
you know why you're eating.
Yeah,
I'm eating bad.
So I didn't eat bad and wow,
my stomach immediately said this is not gonna happen today.
So I get up and I go and literally like,
like three seconds.
I hear it as I'm walking over to go Kev heart.
And as I'm walking by,
a guy gets up,
follows me in the bathroom and he's like,
y'all gotta get a picture man.
And I said,
let me,
let me go to the bathroom when I'm done,
I'll take a picture with you.
I go to the bathroom.
This is a true story.
Hand her Bible hand on the Bible.
I assume the guy is outside the bathroom cause I,
as I'm going,
I seen him and I say what I say,
I get done.
I go to the sink,
wash my hands.
He was just sitting behind a wall and he's like,
got his phone out and I'm like,
he probably did.
He just take me while I was shitting.
Did he put the phone over to thing like I'm about to be on.
Oh my God,
it's over.
This is it.
This is my nightmare.
Here we go.
They're about to put something up of me.
Shitting is the bottom of my feet.
It's whatever.
But he's just waited.
And in that moment was so,
it was so important that he was in the bathroom and,
and as soon as I got a call and let's take an asset,
let's go outside the bathroom.
Yeah,
let's take a picture that's a bathroom.
I said,
I'm not going to,
I'm a nice guy,
man.
I'm gonna take the picture.
He's actually saying didn't want to lose you.
And I'm like,
there's not even a thought.
It's not even a thought about it's a bath.
Right.
So weird is that it's a bad thing,
man.
This is,
this is it.
This is a pretty fucking weird moment,
man.
This is weird when you should waited for me to finish it and I don't know what
you got on your phone.
You're too big for me to ask to go through your phone.
Whatever you get you get.
But I had to go out and take the picture and I remember going back to the table
just like,
what's happening?
What's Hash range at this point?
What is happening?
Yeah.
That didn't exist before.
I think if you were famous before,
people just wanted to get an autograph or shake your hand.
What pat?
We're past.
The autograph stage was the last time you get an autograph.
It's been awhile.
I don't think that,
I don't think I would know how to write it.
I think I would know what to put down.
It's been a minute,
man.
Yeah.
And I don't,
and I want to make this very clear,
you know,
I don't,
I understand.
Like once again,
I want people to more importantly understand the fact that I welcome it.
I welcome the moment that I can talk in and converse with the fame,
but it should be that like it's normal to date.
The moments are better when they're real,
you know,
and after a real moment you,
you get a picture because you're like,
Yo,
he was actually a nice guy or I had no idea that,
that you would be this calm and cool.
You don't even get to see how genuine of a person I am because the first thing
you do,
you stick the camera in the face,
you,
and that's when people think that you're an asshole because they,
they,
they had the intrusive moment that then gets met with it.
Can you,
can you please,
I'm sorry.
You don't have to just take it to my face.
Dang.
You ain't gotta be like that.
Wait,
did look for that.
Yeah.
Turn on you.
Because now you get your moment.
You look for the negative moment.
When did shit circuit and weird for you?
How many years in?
Um,
I know it's been,
it's been pretty crazy.
It's been pretty crazy for like the last four to five,
the last four to five years and the last three,
you know,
if it's gotten insane because now you know,
you're,
you're on the international level,
so it's global and the following theirs is bigger.
Um,
and it's all ages,
which is,
which is really,
really good.
But I think,
you know,
for Comedians it's a different thing because you feel like,
Comedians,
you know,
you're laughing,
we're in your homes,
everything is met with warmth.
So when you see a comedian,
especially if you're a fan of a comedian,
you're associating everything with funny and you're just looking for the funny
moment.
You're,
you're looking past the normal moment,
you know,
it's like you almost are frowned upon if you're normal,
if you're just chill.
Right,
right,
right.
Cause everybody wants to find the moment.
Right.
They thought you were going to be funny all the time.
I'm supposed to,
I was supposed to pop lock
right on site.
You know,
if it's two in the morning and you run into me and I said,
hey,
how you doing?
Man?
That's not enough.